this video is a crash course in
time-saving ChemDraw tricks for people
already familiar with the program if
you're brand new to ChemDraw check out
my ChemDraw basics tutorial first okay
let's get started you can generate
structures quickly from their names
ChemDraw 16 is smarter than ever and
able to generate the structures of drugs
from both trade and generic names using
a database if you're teeing and want to
write some quiz questions for students
to identify functional groups on
interesting molecules this is a great
way to do it
sometimes ChemDraw can't figure out your
structure from the name in this case you
can go online and find a chemical
identifier to use I usually use a smile
string Google the compound name with the
word smiles and then you'll be able to
use chemspider or drug Bank to copy the
smiles string wikipedia has smile
strings also you just need to click show
now paste special from the Edit menu or
use this key command remember when using
websites where many people contribute
data you should always double check your
structures against a vetted source now
suppose your TA and you need to write a
quiz question using the structure of
stearic acid the professor wants all of
the ch2 groups drawn out because the
students aren't familiar with line
structures yet well you can type out
each ch2 by hand but that's pretty
painful and takes a lot of time instead
you can type the methylene group out
once and then making sure the a is still
selected highlight your label and then
double click on any atom where you want
to copy it
let's say one of your lab mates
presented this structure in group
meeting and you can't for the life of
you remember what the CBZ group looks
like select the abbreviation and then
click on expand label in the structure
menu now the carboxy benzyl group is
drawn out for you but it's overlapping
with this other label visit the text
menu and select flush right to anchor it
at the right side but you'll notice our
group looks like it's connected at
methyl rather than nitrogen what we need
to do is type the label in Reverse
beginning with the Emmie let's go back
to our structure with a CBZ group
abbreviated imagine that you miss
remembered how the abbreviation was
written and you capitalized the B now
when we expand the label ChemDraw thinks
this is a carbon bound to a benzoyl
group and our structure contains an
error you can check structures in a
couple ways you can activate chemical
warnings from the view menu and any atom
with incorrect valence or charge gets
boxed in red we can also use the
structure menu to check our structure
this gives us a little more info about
the nature of the error and here it
tells us that carbons valence is not
correct here I've drawn a reaction where
a ketone is converted to an acetal but
my product is much lower on the page
than the starting material and my arrow
really isn't in line either we can
select each object we want to align and
then visit the object menu I'm going to
line top and bottom centers and this
will line up the middle of each of my
molecules now I'll scoot the structure
over a little bit and our scheme is
looking pretty good there's some tricks
for adding text as well when we label
something on the structure ChemDraw
automatically makes it into a formula
however when we're typing text ChemDraw
doesn't know if we want it to be a
formula or not we need to tell the
program this is a formula by selecting
the text and clicking this little ch2
here which makes the selected text into
a formula let's say you heated this
reaction and your PI wants you to use
the Delta symbol to show that from the
View menu select the caret
map window
apparently you can even add emojis in
this version of ChemDraw
will type Delta and a variety of
representations for the character pop-up
to choose from finally we need to align
the arrow with the text select the three
objects and align the centers
I used to make molecules with sugars
connected to aromatic rings when drawing
this structure I can cheat a little and
have ChemDraw generate glucose for me
the sugar was protected so I'll use our
label copying trick from tip to
now when I connect these two parts of
the molecule my bond is crooked and way
too long so I'll click on the structure
menu and clean up structure ChemDraw
automatically corrects bad bond angles
and lengths now I need to add some
groups here when I add them on they're
going to overlap with other parts of my
structure so I'll apply tip 4 and flush
these left notice when I double click to
copy the label down here the same text
flushing is conveniently applied let's
say this is a new compound you just
synthesized and you need to get a mass
spectrum to see if you've actually made
what you think you made you'll need to
know the molecular mass and you can
calculate this quickly by selecting view
and show analysis window you can paste
this info and if you don't need all of
the data you can deselect the items you
don't need pasted finally wouldn't it be
nice to know what to expect when we take
an NMR of this count down from the
structure menu we can generate a
prediction of the NMR shifts now mousing
over any proton in the molecule
highlights it in the spectrum and
vice-versa what's your favorite
time-saving trick in ChemDraw let me
know in the comments and for more
chemistry tutorials subscribe to my
channel